all I know is that that first timer
should we made that show I think I felt
like I was at summer camp with some
really cool people
yeah that I really liked and that was
going to be it he got me school and that
fall the show came out and something
happened I don't think anyone expected
people became so attached these
characters in the story lines and what
we were doing that it became a
phenomenon
[Music]
it blows my mind should be sitting here
with you guys place but on the other
hand it's no surprise being part of the
comic-con tour allows fans to come up
before can tell us what we're their
favorite parts of the show how it
changed their lives or affected them or
help them come get it what are you 19
I'm not a kid anymore it's a real is
gritty it's what it's the way it is
right they're all made up something at
all you were natural and and you know
even when we auditioned I remember them
saying to if you have any acting
experience and I said no one makes it
good because area just wanted is right
in Japanese I'll be fine but you're
basically playing who you are right yeah
yeah that's the best way to do we were a
street version a 901 okay we were so
Street yeah I'm pregnant you help kids
make decisions of their own no you
showed them okay you can go this way you
can go this way which way and then they
went along that's why I do a lot of
other people for some kids it may not be
that they were looking for an answer for
in such situations I think parents want
to know if the kids are up to so half of
our fan base back in the day we're
parents watching so with their kids and
then sparking a dialogue you know that
we're terrified or like I've never
watched not sure yeah and either they're
guilty and we're going to watch fuller
house now okay